[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala me acompaña en el
estudio mar bienvenida buena mañana de
viernes y hoy vamos a hablar del efecto
placebo y empecemos por el principio que
es Buenos días Raúl Así es en general se
habla del efecto placebo para explicar
resultados positivos que no se pueden
explicar determinar por el efecto
directo fisiológico digamos del
tratamiento que recibe un paciente hoy
en día engloba una serie de aspectos
desde lo estadístico hasta lo
neurobiológico no digamos primero por
ejemplo estadísticamente una de las
cosas que suceden es que pues con el
paso del tiempo los pacientes suelen
mejorar una regresión habitual de la
enfermedad no hacia estar bien Entonces
eso estadísticamente puede dar ese pues
esos números que estén equivocados o
digamos modificados Por eso luego por
ejemplo no que el hecho de estar
recibiendo el tratamiento nos
distorsione nuestra percepción sobre los
síntomas en este caso positivamente no
pongo más atención a cómo me siento digo
Bueno me estoy sintiendo mejor y pues
menosprecio un poco los síntomas de
dolor o y sigo teniendo eso es otra cosa
que se ha observado que suele pasar
tercero y aquí empezamos ya abrir la
puerta a la magia del efecto placebo el
condicionamiento farmacológico nuestro
cerebro puede aprender no puede
entrenarse a que cuando tomamos una
pastilla hay unos caminos unas rutas que
se activan por ejemplo como las rutas de
recompensa que producen hormonas
relacionadas con la endorfina O con pues
con la dopamina no que están
relacionadas con el bienestar o incluso
se entrenan medicamentos específicos
gente que le dieron un medicamento el
cerebro respondía de una forma les
dejaron de dar el medicamento para
darles placebo y el cerebro seguía
respondiendo de la misma forma y cuarto
lo que hemos llamado el ritual del
tratamiento no cómo recibimos el
tratamiento que nos reciba alguien en
bata blanca en un hospital que nos miran
que nos pregunten cómo nos atienden si
nos sentimos escuchados si nos sentimos
atendidos Y nos sentimos comprendidos
todas estas cosas tienen un impacto que
ahora veremos en nuestra salud Qué papel
precisamente entonces juega amar este
efecto placebo a la hora de desarrollar
nuevo encantamientos tiene toda la
importancia del mundo No gracias a estos
efectos placebos es que podemos
comprobar la eficacia de muchísimos
medicamentos por primera vez eso Por
ejemplo pasó a finales del siglo 18
había un médico que se llamaba Frank
messmer que trataba a la gente con algo
que llamaba magnetismo animal había
mucho ritual a su alrededor y pues a
Luis XV El rey de Francia organizó una
comisión de expertos para ver si eso era
real o no les hicieron taparse los ojos
y vieron que las personas que no veían
ese ritual recibían por ejemplo o sea
tenían la percepción de lo que creían
imaginaban que estaba pasando sentían
eso y no lo que realmente estaba pasando
esa vez fue la primera vez no que se
intentó superar esta percepción
subjetiva de los tratamientos y sienta
las bases para hoy en día que no sucede
algo que sea muy distinto todos los
estudios clínicos muchas veces Después
le das a un grupo un fármaco que tiene
el componente activo digamos de la
medicación y uno que no muchas veces
pues pasó en pastillitas de azúcar por
ejemplo no y se los resultados y el gran
fundamento de la física moderna hoy en
día para evaluar los medicamentos Es que
este tratamiento tiene que mejorar a la
mente tiene que superar el efecto
placebo tiene que ser mejor que lo que
hacemos y nos sugestionamos nosotros
mismos cuando recibimos tratamientos hoy
en día sigue funcionando de la misma
forma Bueno una gran ejemplo es las
vacunas del covid 19 no todas estas
estudios de los que hemos hablado
ampliamente en los últimos dos años y
medio tienen que ver con esto no y sigue
siendo el estándar Pues de la mayoría de
agencias regulatorias del medicamento en
el mundo sin embargo sigue siendo se
pone cada vez más difícil con el paso
del tiempo en algunos Campos por ejemplo
en el campo del dolor un campo muy
relacionado con nuestros circuitos
neuronales especialmente sugestivo
también muy relacionado entonces con el
efecto placebo Aquí tienen los
resultados de un estudio que se hizo Se
cogieron se haya amalgamaron digamos 85
estudios sobre el dolor neurálgico que
es el dolor de los nervios un dolor
especialmente molesto por cierto no y se
veía que en 1996 la comparación del
tratamiento de los medicamentos respecto
al placebora de 27% esa ventaja que le
sacan en cambio casi 20 años después
esta ventaja se había reducido al 9%,
Entonces cuál puede ser la explicación
que los medicamentos sean peores es poco
probable porque la investigación avanza
Cuál es entonces una de las hipótesis
que se manejan Pues que los estudios que
el efecto placebo ha crecido que se ha
hecho más grande que tiene más defecto
por ejemplo porque los estudios son más
largos también porque hay presión
mediática no como empezó un estudio
nuevo sobre tal la fase 3 clínica no sé
qué no porque también hay más gente
Entonces está como teatralización y
ampliación de los estudios sea
correspondido también con un mayor
beneficio para Muchos pacientes porque
han sentido más efecto placebo Entonces
el placebo Es bueno o es malo pues es
una es una gran debate no ahí hay luces
hay sombras y no se ponen de acuerdo
todavía la comunidad científica mucho
tiempo ha reinado esta percepción de que
el efecto placebo es algo negativo no es
algo que se tiene que compartir un
obstáculo que se tiene que superar
precisamente porque es subjetivo pero
recientemente se empieza a argumentar no
que la percepción subjetiva de una
enfermedad no deja de ser importante voy
a poner un ejemplo no se hizo un estudio
con pacientes de asma unos les daba el
placebo a otros les daban un tratamiento
de estos tipo Pues el ventolín no cuando
compararon Cómo se sentían todos habían
reportados sentirse igual de mejor todos
habían mejorado Cómo se sentían cuando
investigaron como estaban sus pulmones o
sus vías respiratorias solo habían
mejorado los que habían recibido el
tratamiento es un gran ejemplo Por qué
Pues porque nos dice eso no el efecto
placebo no va a curar tu enfermedad no
va a hacer reducir tu tumor no te va a
bajar la presión arterial es
necesariamente pero sí puede cambiar
cómo nos sentimos Y eso no deja de ser
importante pues para pacientes
especialmente en estas áreas donde sean
visto que hay mejoras por ejemplo en el
dolor crónico en la ansiedad en la
enfermedad de colon irritable también
hay otras en que definitivamente no por
ejemplo en el alzheimer o en el cáncer
pero pues se intenta no que en el
placebo capitalice este poder que tiene
que se use que sirvan para remar en la
misma dirección hacia los mismos
tratamientos algo que simplemente una
pequeña reflexión para terminar está muy
lejos de este positivismo de si pienso
que me voy a curar es que me voy a curar
No eso puede ser muy peligroso es como
decirle a un paciente de cáncer quieres
ser pesimista o negativo Entonces ya no
te vas a curar eso no funciona así Pero
entonces por eso Hemos traído una cita
de un doctor tedcapto que es un
investigador del programa de placebo en
el Harvard que dice eso no que el
placebo es una forma que tiene el
cerebro para decirle a nuestro cuerpo
que es lo que nos hace sentir bien Y
definitivamente ahí mi opinión es que
nosotros deberíamos de escuchar y
siempre es bueno Omar por supuesto
pensar positivo que negativamente no en
todos los aspectos de la vida Muchísimas
gracias Marcos Como siempre por toda la
información de salud feliz fin de semana
el lunes por supuesto con más nos vemos